shoot us down but it's multitude of ways
lifting your voice bringing awareness to
the change
recording incidents when they happen
it's a multitude of ways you can fight
back and by the way the shared position
is an elected position yo
you choose your sheriff the sheriff
don't choose you choose the sheriff
unify against this sheriff get him out
of there
that's all you have to do is not by
chance black voters matter is popping up
unified the da as well
elected positions get these individuals
out of position if they're not going to
be equal and just for all
if they're not going to serve you they
serve you they work for you
but in small towns like this they make
it seem like they're the ones in control
no
you put them in position of power you
put them in position of power
let me hear you say people power legal
power
economic power
no peace
[Applause]
and then we will have a representative
from the black lives matter i'm sorry
voters matter to come and speak
right all right i don't really like
speaking of events like this i'm tired
of taking events like this
my name is i'm part of black bonus
matter here in eastern north carolina
and we're here to send a solid daddy to
all of you we shouldn't be seeing things
like what's happening around our country
happened to our people
i'm really tired and i know i'm holding
this sign and says black voters man
but what this really means is that we
mad as a people we matter 365
right going to the days are just it's
just being about voting
right and that's it no we matter all the
time
so but most importantly we have power so
i don't know what the next election is
i don't know but we're going to make
sure we show up
but today's about andrew brown we want
justice for him
he needs to release that body cam
footage
when i say release you're gonna say the
body cam release i say andrew you about
to say brown
i'm pretty sure you had a nickname too
but i wanna say andrew
was his nickname yeah when i say drew
i'm gonna say brown
true
that's right so i hope um andrew's
family is here
i want to let you let them know that we
stand in solidarity with you
all about all of our black voters matter
states we're
12 states around the country we stand in
solidarity uh we love you all and that's
what we're here
we're here to do sometimes you can't do
a whole lot but sometimes you can just
stop showing up
just saying that we love you means a lot
so i don't know look to your left and
right
just say hello i love you that's
one more time when i say drew we say
brown drew
[Applause]
everybody say vote say vote
now say what happens what happens if you
don't vote
if you don't move his name
you
let's make this clear the chief of
police
is hired the sheriff
is elected so if you didn't go out and
vote during the last election
then that might be all of us sharing
maybe while we're standing here today
so understand don't ever say your vote
doesn't count because your vote
does count i'm keith rivers president of
the crosstalk county branch
of the naacp and we want the sheriff
to come out and talk to us
have we seen we've only seen one county
commissioner
an elected official come out and talk
to us we have a right
to know what is going on
we understand we understand that there
is an investigation
we understand that there are things that
cannot be given to us
that cannot be given to the media but we
know that there are things that you
don't need to hide
transparency brings trust
trust brings accountability and
accountability brings justice
and we're here today to seek
and demand justice now these
people that have come in from other
organizations they call them
agitators they are not agitators
they are people that fight for justice
just like we
do on a daily basis many of these people
are my friends
and i and i just hold it so office that
you would call them
agitators they didn't come here to tear
and burn elizabeth city down
people are boarding up their businesses
people are shutting down schools because
they are afraid
they are afraid of us why is it when the
black community stands up for itself
and we stop apologizing for being black
and everybody gets afraid
we bleed like everybody else
my black is beautiful and because we are
pro-black it doesn't make us anti-white
anti-jewish anti-anything it just simply
says that there's a time
has come for this to stop
i am so tired i'm so tired of watching
my brothers and sisters die in the hands
of police
i am so tired of watching my young
brothers go to jail
i am so tired i'm apologizing for
playing black but today it starts
now we are unapologetically
black and we're gonna stand and we're
gonna demand
justice city
you a statement councilman the sbi that
clearly
says that the sheriff has total custody
of this video camera
so about two o'clock today instead of
our sheriff
coming and making itself visible to
everyone
they decided to send out a media release
it says north carolina state bureau
investigation
sbi investigates officer involved
shooting involving pastor tank
county sorry from the periscope county
sheriff's office
riley north carolina the north carolina
state
bureau investigation continues its
investigation into wednesday's officer
involved shooting in elizabeth city
north carolina
involving the passenger county sheriff's
office our special agents are working
this investigation as quickly and as
thoroughly as possible
we understand the need for transparency
evidently and we will release what
information
we can when we're able to release it
as for the release of any body camera
video
it is not it is not the
sbi's decision as to when
and how the body camera video will be
released
in north carolina body worn video shall
be released
pursuant to a court order
any request as it relates to this
release of such video
should be directed to the past county
sheriff's office
or district attorney's office
so right now we're going to hear from
the north carolina community of bill
bund
bill fund of durham north carolina and
then we're going to hit the streets
how y'all doing um like my brother
kerwin said i hate to be here with you
guys but i'm glad to stand in solidarity
i'm the director of the north carolina
community the health and the firm i'm
definitely not a johnson
i bail people out for free and um my
name is muffin hudson
and what i want y'all to really um
understand
that y'all have the power y'all already
have it here y'all don't need us
here we just want to stand in solidarity
and help you with whatever questions you
may have
but y'all have the power this is your
city y'all voting y'all d.a y'all voted
in your sheriff y'all voting your county
commissioners
and y'all voting y'all city council so
you have the power to vote them in you
have the power to go the mouth
same with those judges you can vote them
in you can vote them out if you don't
get what you need
for this for brother drew vote them out
anytime they tell you that your vote
don't matter just know that it does
and that's why they want you to believe
that it doesn't matter because it really
does matter
release the camera release the camera
release the camera
release the video let's change it up
release the video
release the video release the video
release the video release the video
uh
really hard at times like this to find
the right words to say
our city is broken and we're broken on
both sides
when i was driving over here i was
trying to think
of what could be said to help everybody
to understand what needs to be
understood about these police shooters
that's been going across this country
i thought about the founding of this
country when this country was born
i thought about the colonists who fought
against england
against injustice
1776 they fought against injustice
they understood that government would be
and just
against his people we formed a country
we put laws in place we put checks and
balances in place
and still over 200 years later
black people cannot find justice in a
system that was designed to stop
injustice
we can't live like that anymore
we got to make some changes you have to
understand and identify
when you are wrong whether you carry a
badge or not
you have to identify when you are wrong
shooting an unarmed person is wrong
shooting an honorable person
it is wrong wrong since 1776
and it is still wrong today the man
is entitled to due process
what exactly does that mean we go to
court
we have an idea in this nation that
everybody
don't care if you're guilty you are
innocent
you are
you said that there would be no fatal
shootings in this city
we are holding you to your
i would just words to make clear
the young man that did the shooting is a
native of lithus city
and he's 26 years old
it's not all true
[Music]
everybody
i'm a father and this young man
and anybody that's watching you you tell
them this is where they need to be
yes
[Music]
god
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
we shall overcome
[Applause]
we shall overcome
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you